[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show that's where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about life
i'm ken coleman ramsey personality and
host of the ken coleman show on the
ramsay network joined by my colleague
john delony
who is ramsey personality as well and
host of the doctor john dalone show
on the ramsey network and we together
are here for you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight
eight two five five two two five if
you're new to the show
or new to us dr john deloney is
are you licensed i'm not you're not but
you're trying to
not but you're trained that's correct
you're a psychologist by trade
counselor counselor by trade yeah okay
oh i see see that helped me there
we go bottom line is we can figure it
out you understand
people i watch enough instagram they
could probably come out oh i love that
instagram expert i'm an instagram i'm an
expert no uh so
john we could take calls emotional
health mental health
relationship issues that's marriage
parenting
hey one of the topics that john and i
love to team up on is
pretty nasty situations at work yeah so
if you are truly in a toxic situation
not difficult people but i mean
maybe abusive situation a really
dead-end situation at work
we'd love that call today um because
john
can dive in on that and then i can come
in as well we can talk about an exit
strategy we love those calls
uh and then of course i focus on doing
work that you were created to do
living and working on purpose
specifically but we look at the
professional contribution
and then of course we're gonna take your
money questions so if you're new to us
in the show
uh welcome aboard we're gonna talk about
life whatever you got
and uh we enjoy it we have a lot of fun
together
so john you're ready to go you ready to
get to it let's do it man all right
let's go to anna to start us off in
fayetteville
north carolina anna how can we help
good afternoon thank you so much for
having me on your show
i just want to say that you are greatly
appreciated um for all that you do so
thank you so
much well thank you so much and what's
going on today
yeah so um just a quick background so
i'm 24 years old about to turn 25
i work full-time and i'm also pursuing
my doctorate degree full time so just a
little busy there
and so so i'm in the process of looking
for a new job
um and interviewing and i'm just having
a lot of doubts
about my on my abilities as a young
professional
and always try to kind of self sabotage
due to my anxiety and doubts um and so
i've always just been very hard on
myself
and lately i've been so stressed out
that i'm just having a hard time
focusing and falling asleep
and so i guess my question is how do i
get rid of these doubts and gain
self-confidence as a young professional
and also how do i begin to practice
self-compassion
um to improve my mental health wow a lot
of stuff there
let me ask a couple questions and i'm
gonna let the good doctor start
and then i'll jump in for an assist
potentially
what is the doctorate for what is the
goal
um so the goal is to do healthcare
administration
my goal is to become a medical director
or medical manager
okay great all right john you want to
dive in first yeah let me ask a couple
questions so
um where did you learn
who taught you how to talk to yourself
in a way that you would never let
somebody talk to one of your patients
um i don't know um
who told you you were lazy and you
weren't that smart
and you're probably gonna screw this up
who told who
who where'd you learn that
um i i wouldn't necessarily say
that i learned it um from my parents
because they've never told me
that i was a failure but i think it was
just something
not not being a failure has always been
something that my parents has
instilled in me so i
was i i was raised by a single mom
um and it was not it was difficult at
times
um and sometimes our parents sometimes
our parents
those we love our coaches or teachers um
church leaders who are
the adults in our lives they may not
always say
hey you're an idiot or if you fail
you're going to let us all down
but sometimes they can imply that you
can pick that up right so it may be in
the ethos here's what i'm trying
what i'm getting at the first and
foremost thing is you got to learn to
talk to yourself in a way that's
respectable
and that is dignified and the way that
you treat other people which i know you
do you wouldn't be getting into
healthcare administration if you didn't
care about people
you didn't care about patients and
doctors you've got
to start talking to yourself in a way
that honors you right when it comes to
self-compassion
well let me just let me give you two
things number one some of my darkest
seasons
of negative self talk of self-defeating
just those loopty loops was when i had
spent
year on year inside of a textbook inside
of a classroom
inside of working a full-time job inside
of being
completely and totally burned out at
both ends exhausted
no fun no community no joy no production
just reading reading thinking or
thinking reading we were not designed to
stay in our own heads by ourselves all
the time
so what i want you to do in the middle
of this doctoral program in the middle
of this
full-time job and this job search is get
out and do things with your hands with
other people
go serve some other people make a
regular routine monday night get
together or tuesday night get to
whatever it looks like
and you may be late on some assignments
you may be behind
i don't care because at the end of the
day if you slide across the stage with
your doctorate
and you are completely burned out and
anxious and fried you'll be of no use to
anybody including yourself
right when you take care of yourself
then you can do your best work then you
contribute to yourself to your community
to your classroom to your
to your academic career then you start
seeing success
and when you start seeing success then
your body feels good about you
you can't talk yourself into
self-compassion you walk into it
right anna i just i just want to ask you
are you afraid of being your mom
um yes because
um she has she has um sorry
um she has always taught me
not not to um she's always wanting me to
be better
and i love her i love her to death
don't defend her don't defend her hold
on keep going keep going
she has sacrificed so much for me and my
siblings
um and i guess i'm just afraid of
i'm just i get it anna here's the deal
i didn't i didn't ask you that question
to put you in a tough position i
i asked the questions i wanted you to
hear what i heard
you're afraid in this whole pursuit of
of the doctrine and the job
that you're going to fail because you
come from not much
and i think you're having a hard time
believing that you belong yeah that's
what i heard john
i i want to tell you this anna you have
the talent to do this you
know it you have the passion to serve
people the way that you've
envisioned it and you have a
responsibility to be the best version of
you anna because somebody's on the other
end of that
don't you dare believe the lie that you
can't do
what it is you know you're supposed to
do you're not your mom you're anna
now go do it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman uh joined by my colleague dr
john deloney as we take your
calls this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five
is the toll-free number what are you
waiting on i mean we had tears in our
first call john
people are ready yeah man it's a hard
season for folks
let me point something out i i you and i
both the nature of our shows
we take a lot of calls that have a lot
of emotion around right
work and purpose and then emotional and
mental health relationships
um if you feel like as you're listening
today you're going okay
i'd like to call john and ken but
ah man it's i don't want anybody to know
it's me we'll change your name
yeah kelly will change your name your
location you can change some of the
facts around where you are so that we
can protect you
yep you you got to name into that
absolutely and so i we don't mention
that all the time
but i mention it more and more on my
show because i want people to feel
like hey i can get some help right here
i don't have to
totally expose me and my situation yeah
i don't want to get burned so i want to
put that out there i don't know if
anybody's supposed to hear that today
but we're going to offer you that kelly
will take great care of you
because we want to help you so don't let
that be a barrier maybe today's your day
i don't know ken i want to touch on that
last call for a second yeah um
a common maybe the most common thing
that if i continue to unpack and unpack
and unpack and
sometimes these calls are hard because
you get you know seven minutes and five
minutes
that's it is we have so many
voices looping around in our heads
that may have come from a parent may
have come from
a coach or a teacher whoever an old
boyfriend or whoever
and over time that voice
that that thing they said that hurt us
that lived in us we're not gonna be
enough
you're you're not gonna do that you
might as well just do this you're not
gonna make it whatever whatever that
negative talk is
it morphs into our voice and we walk
around
thinking that we're mostly pretty honest
and that we're mostly pretty smart
right and when we start telling
ourselves those things
in our own voice we believe it and then
our bodies
literally respond chemically to that
truth
that is you're probably not going to
make it you're probably not that smart
you're not we aren't doctorate people
yep right
you're not senior leader we are nurses
we are not doctors right we are not
right whatever the hierarchy is they're
not
you know not to belittle nurses but at
some point you've got to get around
other people that you trust whether it's
calling the show whether it's getting a
group of people
and let new voices into your heart and
so they challenge it right that say no
and you're not crazy when you feel like
i'm not enough because that's what you
know that's what you've been told
and you got to get some encouragement
around you got to get some people who've
walked alongside you
to help you say nope we're we're going
off into the jungle
off the normal path and we're going to
create something new i want to stay here
i just think somebody needs to hear this
yeah
i'm so glad you brought us back we're in
john's talk about the call in the last
segment
uh this is a bright bright woman uh i
mean 24 about to be 25 on our way to a
doctorate and just
i don't i don't have any confidence
right and you asked her where did you
learn to talk to yourself that way i
love that
position william james
considered widely the father of modern
psychology one of my favorite william
james quotes i'm sure you've heard it
no matter how absurd something is i want
everybody to hear this
no matter how absurd something is
if it is repeated often enough people
will believe it he said that
haven't you checked out the news the
last year yes but i don't want to get
into that
i'm saying that to your point this is
the guy who's considered
you know one of the gurus yeah and he's
right just say it enough
when we first hear it sometimes it's
absurd but we hear it a couple times
three
four times five times and all of a
sudden to your point you begin to
believe it and then once we believe it
is that
when it becomes our voice it it well
what happens is when you believe it you
start seeing it everywhere
oh isn't that the truth right so when
you believe the truth
i kind of screw stuff up i'm kind of a
loser then when
somebody honks at you in the highway you
go yeah they think i'm a little
know how to drive yeah they think i'm a
terrible driver or when your boss says
hey
great job in this report i need you to
change the font next time you go ah
because i suck at writing
right and instead of going true you
missed the whole hey great report
or you missed the whole um hey i just
wasn't paying attention right yeah
no you're not a crappy driver yeah yeah
cut somebody off move on with your life
right
so the other it works the other way
though ken
when you look at your kids and you hold
them in their face and you say
hey i want you to know i saw how you
just talked to your sister yeah
you treated her with respect and i
wanted to let you know that that honored
her that honored my family and that's my
daughter that honored me son and i'm
proud of you yeah when you catch your
kids doing right
they begin to stand up a little taller
when you when they mow the yard and you
call them back out and say hey you did a
good job but you're not finished yep
and they learn how to do a good job not
through you just praising them
mindlessly and nonsensically but you
call them back and you call them back
then it works the other way they begin
to see that
they start to see hey i'm pretty good
right that's exactly right and so it
works both ways
but when you find yourself so here's
here's where that last call got me
i'm got a book deadline i got chapters
due on wednesday
my family left town on purpose so that i
could have some
writing time yeah again i saw the cookie
dough i'm laying eggs man
oh you're not getting it i'm struggling
struggling i'm really struggling
struggling with it
anybody who's written a book no you find
these moments where it's just you get
stuck and it's just like you're walking
to quagmire
and then the talk comes yeah and these
stories i've been telling myself since i
was a middle schooler give me one right
you willing to share
yeah yeah give me one give me one you
heard last night this is this morning
it's 4 45 i'm writing is this who
are you know why you can't think of x y
and z yeah because you got no business
doing this yeah
yeah you you're you're over you're who
do you think you are
you know what i mean right and it's it's
like
oh yeah and then you go back and try to
read the top paragraph and
read through it again and you realize
that's probably not that great of a
paragraph you start seeing it everywhere
right and the loop comes back and then
all of a sudden
i'm just gonna go you know what makes
this make this feel better
diet coke and cookie dough for breakfast
that'll solve my problem right right
or i'm gonna scroll through instagram
for a while so you get in these negative
loops and so
i've been where she is when you're at
the i have two end of a doctor program
and you're thinking
i am fried cooked burned i'm exhausted
and all those old stories wherever they
come from yeah right
um and so man get around other people to
carry your bodies to kill your minds and
when you have those seasons of
of well you're just beating yourself up
man yeah stop
yeah i agree i just add to this
practically real quick when we
confuse ourselves because this is that's
confusion it's nonsense but
it's nonsense but it kind of confuses us
because i'm on this path to a phd
and yet i got these voices going you
don't belong it's a confusing time
right so one little thing that i think
people need to do
and i try to remind people on the show
is let's retreat back to clarity for a
second let's let's retreat from the
dialogue and let's come back
and what you're saying is right and many
times retreating to clarity is in the
is in the safety of the clarity of
people who know us well and can be
objective and tell us the truth
that's right and say you're not an
imposter yeah you really
are bright yeah and you're gonna crush
this phd program or whatever
whatever the thing is right and actually
you've always been this kind of person
who just loves people or
jumps in and what whatever the whatever
the type of work is or whatever the the
journey is
is leading towards and when we can kind
of retreat back and go wait a second i
do have what it takes
i actually have the talent from the
creator of the universe
i actually love this and it
matters deeply to me it's a wonderful
elixir
into fear and doubt and we can get some
facts let's call this
what it is there's the other side of
that which i know there's people driving
down the road going oh yeah but so yeah
let's just acknowledge it
having a bunch of you go bros around you
isn't helpful either
no no that's not that's right you also
need i need somebody in my life who did
this morning who said
just start writing yes stop all the
notes and stallone
start putting words on paper right so
there is people who call you out yeah
i'm really glad you said that this is
not going to the posse who just says man
you got it no it's somebody girl you're
right it's somebody specifically saying
you have the talent to do this
you got the passion you're gonna have to
wake up and do it so i want three pages
by ten o'clock yeah right whatever the
thing is so it's both in
that's right but that's good i love
doubling back on
we gotta have people in our life you
gotta be a steward of your body and your
mind that's right and you gotta have
those moments where
you can stop and honor yourself and talk
to yourself signify to yourself i think
it's a nearly 80-year study from harvard
the largest most impressive
study on relationships in history and
they've come up with a conclusion that
says 95
of your success or failure 95 of your
success for failure in life
it's based on people you hang out with
that's who you're married to and you
know who we hang out with a lot
that person in the mirror that's the
truth
we often treat that person like crap
that's the person we listen to the most
oh and treat the worst all right good
stuff
all right triple eight eight two five
five
is the number what are you waiting on dr
john deloney ken coleman waiting on
you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues thrilled to
have you with us
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
dr john deloney we're taking your calls
about
life relationships
your work your money whatever you want
to talk
to us about we will take the call well i
guess it's not whatever we're not going
to do sports talk
i'll do sports talk i'd love to do
sports talk but james doesn't even know
what sports is i love his
producers just such a music guy kelly
knows way more about sports than james
and so that's a little awkward for you
but your producer madison knows more
about sports than all of us combined
well said touche touche uh hey
uh john before we get to the calls i
know a lot of people out there are busy
my goodness summer is busier than the
school year
my wife stacy's running around like
crazy from ball practice the grocery
store
and you kind of forget sometimes what
your kids are doing what they're
watching but they're learning from you
more is caught and taught and that's
especially true about money for most
kids the best financial education
they'll get is watching how you handle
your money so this summer we want to
help you teach kids about money
and make it fun the adventure pack is a
family favorite
that includes the new story time
collection financial peace junior
the smart saver bank and more and each
sibling can get their own kit
or if you've got a teen who wants to
make some money the teen entrepreneur
toolbox i've got one in my house
fabulous tool show them how to safely
start their own business this summer
they can turn their hobby into a real
business you can teach your kids
the right way to handle money while
they're young so they never have to deal
with money mistakes
like maybe you did or are doing
this we can you can save up to 80 off by
shopping
the kids and teen sale by going to the
online
store at ramseysolutions.com
store that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash store all right let's go to san
antonio texas where jim
joins us on the line jim how can we help
hey guys how are y'all
we are living the dream jim what are you
doing
well i think we are too good um
this week we hit our
edm yeah that's everyday millionaire for
uh newbies
way to go jim oh uh
we took the financial piece university
class
back in the 90s and
did they have color tv back then
oh john i'm
62 now all right
it it was tough it was through our
church a
couple mentored us and we took the class
it it was hard just getting started yeah
um i took sack lunches to work
i worked as much overtime as i could i
probably deprived my children a little
bit of fun
so we nitpicked on our budget
a lot and i was able to
pay the house off in 15 years instead of
a 30-year note
and we started investing in a ranch and
bought it at negotiated half price
wow
so now my wife wants to celebrate our
40th anniversary
big so i'd like to
take her on cruise next summer i just
i'm
guilty as heck because i've never seen
um money like this
i mean i have it's real estate
the ranch is paid for the house is paid
for
and jim jim take her on the cruise
brother stop
talking up the phone why are we even
talking to you
what are you doing i i grew up in a
large family a large family and
for christmas we would get those little
plastic gi joe men
yeah i love those things and they put
five or six of them in a paper bag and
staple it and put your name on it yeah
jim jim jim jim jim you're just doing it
again john please help this man with all
this guilt he's experiencing for
what is going on here john break this
your heart is good
yes you're great your model is good and
somewhere along the way
stuff meant stuff was had by people who
were other than you they were the other
right and now there's a psychological
shift where you've become the other and
you're still jim
you're still a great guy you're still a
good guy who loves his wife who loves
his kids who works really hard who's
diligent
who has taken years and years to do
things right
go on the cruise and listen enjoy
every second of it and if you can't
breathe
donate some money to a local charity to
a local church to make yourself feel
better
you don't need to do that you've earned
it my guess is you're already somebody
who gives generously
go on the cruise that poor woman has put
up with you for
40 years yeah i mean jim
dress for every day of the cruise you
need to let go
man 40 years come on
like the all the drinks all the
everything yeah listen
and you got to go on that weird water
slide all the weird crap you've got to
do all of it
go to everything and do an excursion
every day you have got to go blow some
money
you got to blow some money it's therapy
right john here's what hey here's
don't do that but here's the in all
seriousness jim here's what's going to
happen
here's what's going to happen um is that
transition that was stuck in our head
that's right back on that first day was
live like nobody else
so one day you can live like nobody else
which is now
that's now and you're gonna realize
that the beauty of all of this was the
was the journey
the beauty was you locked arms with the
most important woman
on the planet for you and y'all walked
through hell and back together
you sacrificed your time your kids your
dreams all that stuff but you did it
together
and y'all are tough and you're resilient
and you raised great kids you a member
of your community
go on a cruise yeah my goodness okay
and enjoy every second of it so much
yeah listen
let me explain might blow some money he
needs to budget
the old envelope the blow envelope they
need to go spend some money on the
cruise he has to live
like no one else on this cruise and
celebrate 40 years of matrimony
that's exactly right all of it man just
go do an excursion
get her some jewelry i i mean dude man
way to go and just say if you feel bad
on the way back
give some money away but you won't right
man
go you've worked hard brother good for
you um
let's break that down because we get
that call on a regular basis
you started there i mean there really is
a is it guilt or shame
combo both um why so because
it's about identity right and what often
happens to dave and i have talked about
it often
our identity shifts into i was a failure
yeah and when i cross this finish line
which is debt-free
everything's gonna be okay and it's not
and then
if the bar moves to when i become an
everyday millionaire
then i'm gonna be okay there is no
external solution to internal holes
right
there is that childhood poverty where
you got three little
army men that's right and your mom and
dad said be happy with it and they were
okay that's okay that's right his mom
and dad were bossed in their butts to
make that work
right that's great but there's this move
this idea that if you've worked really
hard for 50 years and you've
done things the right way and you've
amassed wealth that you're somehow a bad
person
that you're not a good human anymore
right or that you somehow
and it's all about that spirit a million
dollars isn't going to heal you
but it's not going to kill you either
right so go on
this trip it's about identity am i
somebody who looks at
others or am i somebody who works really
hard towards a goal i get it
and we're going to move on right yeah
it's incredible work man
yeah it really is since the 90s 30 years
yeah yeah and and painful yeah
uh still he he still feels the pain
that's right
same as dave will tell you i remember
the moment
i got the bank notice yeah the same as i
remember
my senior year in high school when i was
when i dropped the baton
in first place the model really i
remember that and it ricochets through
your life
yep except for the fact is you have
changed your lifestyle
yeah and you're never going to go back
no so use the budget
yeah to go on the cruise and enjoy it
man
and just have a blast and take your
grandkids out to the ranch
yeah i love it that's good good for him
jim we really appreciate you
happy anniversary yep uh 40 years we
didn't talk about that that's incredible
40 years what a milestone man that's big
we're all trying to get on that team
you're a unicorn that is quite a
accomplishment and you're a good dude
we're having some fun with you because
we want you to go
enjoy the fruits of your labor that's
the whole reason i think john's right
as you're on that cruise reflect on how
great the journey itself was
not the fruits all right don't move more
of your calls coming up next this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show america
thrilled to have you with us i'm ken
coleman joined by john dolone and we are
taking your calls the shower triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
let's go to anna who joins us in olympia
washington anna how can we help
hi guys thanks for taking my call um i
wanted to get your input on trying to
balance kind of the live for today
attitude with
long-term paying off debt and savings
goals i'm an emergency medicine doctor
and
you know see people who have sudden
death or i walk in a room and diagnose
somebody with cancer out of the blue and
so i have this kind of
you know perspective that that i don't
really know how long
myself or my family members have and so
balancing that
live for today versus you know paying
off medical school debt etc just hoping
to get your perspective
yeah that's a very interesting
interesting perspective that you have
it's kind of in your face all the time
so i've spent
right um several years researching and
walking alongside
um doctors and the mental health of
doctors
okay and one of the things that is
and same with lawyers same with
preachers obviously i grew up in the
home of a homicide detective
and one of the the bellwether moments
for me was when i realized
that those who who work
in the pain of other peoples for a
living
over time their bell curve begins to
shift
and so i've got this funny there's a
it's a funny family story that wasn't
funny at the time now it's funny
um i was a kid my dad took me to
baseball practice i was like 10. i was
in this
suburban north houston little community
um the worst thing i ever knew that
happened is somebody spray painted
something on somebody right i mean
nothing big
and i left the back door open standing
wide open we went to baseball practice
behind the fence a fence that was locked
we got home and my dad looked at me and
he said
the door's open and he
went he proceeded to clear the room
as though it was a police scene as it
was a military scene
and i remember being nine or ten and we
laughed about this now i remember being
nine or ten thinking
that's a bit much you know what i mean
but here's the thing
yeah a hundred percent of his day was
dealing with things that statistically
never happened to anybody except it does
right so fast forward to your situation
you're a doctor who all day every day
what you do
is you go into people's this is never
going to happen to me and you tell them
but it happened to you and over time
that's that secondary trauma weighs you
down it begins to
infiltrate the way you see the world it
it think of it as bricks in a backpack
it begins to lean you over too
you're not hurting but you're
experiencing other people's pain all day
long
all day long all day long and it begins
to shift the way you see the world
it's a new pair of glasses it makes you
think what does it even matter
i could just get hit by a car on the way
out of here and there's a gift to that
you know how precious life is most
people don't
and there's a weight to that which is
you could get hit by a car and you
probably
won't and so i've lived in that same
thing working in crisis working hard
conversations with folks day after day
after day for year after year after year
and the way i balance that is
recognizing
it could and so i'm prepared for the it
could but also living like
it probably won't because it probably
won't does that make sense
yeah yeah is there i'm just curious
anna is there a specific area of tension
where you're going i
i'm i'm busting it right now maybe give
us a little bit more detail about where
this tension
it's it's a really brilliant question
and i think john diagnosed it
beautifully but i'm just curious where's
the practical tension for you right now
well um as you guys know the training is
long so i mean i
i was gazelle intense with my entire
life for like seven years and
and the loans and and the money became
like this idea of monopoly money so
when i came out i was probably negative
900k
with my doctor house my two cars all my
student loans and it really didn't mean
anything and then there was this weight
after a few years on me of
you know what is weighing me down and
when i actually looked at it was like oh
my god if something happens to me
my whole family's life is going to be
destroyed and so working
back to like you know get that paid down
get that paid down but just after
a while it's like okay do i not go on
vacations with my kids just with that
that enormous amount of debt you know
that's going to take a decade to pay off
do i put off those vacations with my
kids do i work more
to make more money to get the shovel
bigger to pay it off
when you know again i have these
experiences
where i'm taking care of pediatric
cancer patients or a 40 year old woman
who comes in bed you know that was
totally healthy that is my
same age and so it just the the idea
of putting vacations off missing their
ball games to work more
all that even though i know you know
yeah i need to get out of bed it's just
it's hard
to trade that you know you're exhausted
yeah you're exhausted
i mean that's let's just own that are
you a double income one income what's
the situation
uh i'm just one income my my spouse
stays home to
uh to stay at home with the kids and um
what's your situation right now yeah i
get it and
i think that's great what's your i'm
about half i've yeah i've got
i've got it down by about half i'm about
um 400 still in debt with my house
and student loans okay so let's take the
house out of it yeah how much loan
how much how much in student loan about
120
okay you are gazelle intense for 120
more and then you're going to go on a
vacation
got it seriously yeah we even
we even have separate baby steps for
each one of those things
credit card debt and yeah what i'm
saying like
and you can knock that out you're you're
what an emergency room
doctor yeah yeah yeah
yes you can crush that 120. and then
chill relax on the house so we put the
house
in baby step six right okay and we do
that on purpose
so you're a lot closer than you realize
and
and i also think that you've paid enough
off
are you guys not taking vacations is
that where you really are you've not
taken vacations in years
no no we have but then i have this guilt
of like oh that money could have gone
toward the debt you know and my student
loans
are you know low two percent and would
and would go away if i die so it's kind
of like well
is my priority paying off my house so if
something happens to me
my my young kids and my spouse will have
somewhere to live and my
student loans go away you know it's just
a strange situation
yeah you know what john on this
situation i mean okay i'm trying to sit
here i hear what she's saying you paid
off 500 grand so far
yeah yeah go go on vacation yes i i
think now you've got the point where
a you know how to budget and you can
live a normal life and you're still
knocking these loans out right you do
not yeah we tell gazelle intense for
people that are in i mean first of all
we want everybody to be gazelle intense
but that i i think there's some
relativism to this it's like you've
knocked out the credit cards in the cars
and you're not swimming anymore in debt
you you are in a situation where with
your income
you are gonna knock this out i'm not
saying you're not intense
but to translate gazelle intensity in
your situation to
we're not going to go on vacation and
i'm never going to see kids
i don't think that's your situation i
take a deep breath and enjoy life
and keep being disciplined and doc let
me tell you this
um man i'm gonna go speak to a medical
school in the fall so i'm gonna be as
direct with you as i will with those
students okay
um you're brilliant you you wouldn't be
entrusted with the lives of others if
you weren't
and so let me say it this way this is
not a math problem
this isn't an interest rate problem this
is an inflammatory response problem
this is an existential problem this is a
weight that you carry
all of the time problem yep and so you
can justify the
the even your language my family would
be destroyed you know what they wouldn't
they'd have to rent a house or a
one-bedroom apartment
but they wouldn't be destroyed yeah
right and that is the language of
secondary
trauma right that's an exhausted person
who helps other people for a living
and then goes home and has to be a mom
too and so
you've got to got to take care of
yourself
at some point afterwards guys i really
appreciate it after sprinting for seven
years nine years twelve years
you're gonna run out of gas and this
that car is gonna stop in the road
yeah you probably should go talk to
somebody go start taking care of
yourself take care of your family
knock that 120 out and then whoo breathe
next month's budget let's move it around
a little bit and let's put a little
little day spa appointment in there
you know i only made three or four of
those five or six of those well i was
just starting her out
just getting her started to relax i love
it all right hey i want to thank our
producer james hiles our associate
producer call screener kelly daniel
i want to thank my colleague dr john
dolone for hanging out
and we want to thank you america this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story live from the headquarters of
ramsey solutions broadcasting for the
dollar car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it is where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
life so many different facets to your
life obviously we're talking money
we'll talk about your relationships
we'll talk about your work your dreams
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
dr john dolone and we
are ramsey personalities and we are here
for you this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five the
number is triple eight
eight two five five two two
five so let's get to the phones mo is
up in milwaukee
mo how can we help ken john how are you
oh we're living the dream what are you
doing that's great to hear i'm i'm
kind of living the dream i just
graduated college hey congratulations
way to go moe what did you graduate with
a degree in
um i graduated a degree in electrical
engineering and i found a job straight
out of school and i just started about a
month ago come on man very cool
way to go mo way to go man you're
killing it how can we help you guys
thank you guys um i have an issue though
i'm nineteen thousand five hundred
dollars in debt because i
agree um and i
do have a second issue on top of that
which is why i'm calling my car broke
down
i don't have a car um i have had the
same car since high school and it's a
cheap
14 year old car and it broke down i
don't know what steps to take next
i have two options i can stop paying off
debt which i'm currently doing to save
up for a car
which will take about two or three
months or my option two
is fix the car now for the price of it
it's currently valued at about a
thousand bucks and the fix is about 800
but the issue with that option is i'll
keep paying monthly payments to fix it
to my car dealer and i don't know which
to op which of the two options to take
why would you have to keep paying you
don't have 800 800
in cash i do have it saved but the issue
is since it's
since it is an old car it's been giving
me a headache for a few months now and i
i have been fixing it here and there
um i average about 300 every three
months just fixing it
um so i'm afraid that that's going to
continue because it is an old car and it
will keep breaking down
how much money did you make um make
about 67 right out of school
yeah and how much do you have saved
about
six yeah dude with the amount of money
you're making
and what you've got saved um you can go
get another
car that's you know uh still not you
know i wouldn't call it
necessarily a beater but i think a 5000
on the car is more than enough for you
and you can get a decent car for five
grand i'm looking all the time i've got
a 15 year old gonna be 16.
i'm in that market right now yeah some
good stuff out there john
at 5000 hey moe listen to me i talked to
a senior leader in this company today
and they asked the question should i buy
this car for five thousand dollars
and what you're experiencing right now
is something i experience with you get
out of college you get your first job
you're making your big boy paycheck
and you go to work and everyone else has
a nice car yep and then you feel like a
schmuck exactly yeah
and you got to pay for student loans not
that i'm feeling it's not that i'm
feeling like it's not that i'm feeling
that i have to keep up with my friends
um i don't necessarily feel like i have
to go out and get a nice flashy car i
just want something reliable where i
don't have to keep
paying to fix exactly got it which is
what we're telling you to do you can
afford it
and you could keep with the baby steps
and go going but you've got
you've got essentially an emergency fund
which is out of the order of the baby
steps right
but in this situation a car is is
something that you need
and you truly are driving a beater that
at this point i don't think it makes
sense to spend 800
on a car that you know has been giving
you that much trouble when you've got
the cash
to go get something that's affordable
get right back on
the debt elimination on the snowball and
crush this is the 19-5
just student loan debt yes it's just
student loan debt it actually started at
22-5 and i paid off a few grand
out of college out of my savings from
that i just didn't want to keep
putting more out of my savings into this
debt so i'd
to leave myself hanging you know well
but again
uh you got you've got a real emergency
here okay
and uh but we want you to work the baby
steps the way we teach you because the
reality is is that if the car wasn't
falling apart
uh all you need is a thousand dollars uh
in your emergency fund
and then you you're gonna knock this 195
out really quick
mo yes sir do you do not under any
circumstance for
any reason pay more than five thousand
dollars for
another car you got it yep okay i'll
take
i'll take that for sure i know you're
going to go
and you're going to be tempted and
you're going to say i could just and
then i get
5 000 bucks a to and fro car leave a
thousand dollars in the emergency fund
and go like crazy to get that
student loan paid off yep then at the
end of this year
you're debt free then you can save for a
car that you want to drive around
yep question for you john you if your
name was mo
when people came over to your house
would you yell at him a thousand
okay every time i thought you might and
i think i would too as well so there's
two votes
absolutely and if my name was mo i would
expect everyone to yell welcome to mo
when i walked into the room i think so
too i love it
all right let's go to dawn in pittsburgh
pennsylvania dawn how can we help
i guess hi i am uh in a situation i've
never been in before
where the job i took uh pays
wonderful money i have started paying
off my credit card bills um and since i
can continue on with this job
my goal is to pay off all my debt uh
probably within a year
all right um what i'm looking at right
now here's what's so hard having been
an individual who worked who always
paycheck to paycheck like you know
never you know something always coming
up um
i approximately like um
probably have at least a good one
thousand dollars
left over every week i'm making about
two grand a week
um so with my expenses are paid i have
about a thousand dollars every week
i'm just so nervous to take that money
and you know
put it on all my debt so
should i be doing this on a week-to-week
basis hitting this that hard
or waiting all at one time and taking
care of my debt
at the end of the month how much debt do
you have
it's okay i'm sorry my son just walked
in the room
i'm so sorry that's all right john has
voices in his head like that all the
time so
he's one of my son now my son just came
into the room
so we only got about a minute and a half
real quick how much debt do you have
um i thought it cost me uh 37 000. 37.
everything 47. everything okay great
that's everything yeah here's the deal
whether you do it
uh you don't save it up when the money's
coming in
it's whatever your monthly budget is
you're putting after all expenses are
paid
and you've got your emergency fund of a
thousand dollars you're putting
everything
yeah i know and so you're putting it all
towards the debt you're going to knock
this out really fast
don at some point you got used to
everything being on fire you didn't love
it and it scares you
but you're used to everything being on
fire and you don't know that you
you don't believe way down there that
you deserve to have all
you do you have an emergency and it's 47
000
of debt pay it off and you are gonna
sleep in a way you haven't slept in
years
and then you're gonna watch that
thousand dollars a week come in and come
in and come in a thousand dollars a week
over
and you're gonna look up halfway through
this time next year you're gonna be debt
free you're gonna have 20 some thousand
dollars in cash in the bank and you
are going to be a woman of
peace yeah for the first time in a long
long time
don't overthink it don act and before
you know it your life has changed
forever
really good stuff thank you for the call
yeah really fun all right hey
good news there's more ramsay show
coming up
don't move
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague john delony and
we are taking your calls about your life
your money also
your contribution in the form of your
work how many of you want to get
promoted you want a bigger shovel well
i'll take those questions how many of
you are in a really desperate
nasty gnarly situation at work john and
i will
take those questions as well triple
eight eight two five five
two two five how about some relationship
issues
well we're here triple eight eight two
five
five two two five let's go to anna who
joins us in colorado springs
colorado and anna we're here to help
what's up
hi um so i just have a question i was
hoping to get some advice on if you
think i'm doing
good in my career track um i recently
about a year and a half ago made a
decision to leave a better paying job to
switch careers to be in finance because
that's where my passion is
and i started at the bottom and i
recently got a promotion
but it was kind of a small promotion and
so i'm still
only making about 33 five a year
and i'm 28 years old and i just feel
like i'm behind the curve
do you have any advice for me yes relax
the great news is is that you are doing
the work that you want to do you know
you want to be in finance
and you're young and you you made a
switch
and i get it um because here's what's
associated with that switch
i was making more money over here i'm
doing the work i love
but uh oh i'm 28 i'm getting closer to
30 and maybe some of my friends are
making more money i'm starting to
question
oh what did i do what did i do does that
sound about right
yeah it does yeah so here's the deal
let's talk for a moment about the future
what's the latter look like for you
forget about the timeline
i'm just talking about the latter what
work are you doing as you continue to
move up
what's that dream job for you your
professional pinnacle
uh for me i really like where i'm at
right now but i want to be a financial
advisor eventually
my particular credit union that i work
at doesn't have that
track because they use an outside source
but i do get to see it and i get to
talk to that financial advisor that we
work with
on a fairly regular basis so i'm getting
into the finance and i'm learning about
it still um
but yeah it's going to mean probably a
shift from my company to another couple
well there's no question let's just call
that out
you don't have that position in your
company so that's great so what we're
going to do is now we're going to switch
ladders you're on the ladder right now
you're getting great experience really
proud of you you're doing a great job
but eventually we're looking and i don't
mind you looking now
but you know your industry a little bit
better than me obviously so when is the
right time when you have the right
experience to make a move
to to another company where we can move
into the financial advisor role but
here's the deal
you know what a financial advisor does
and you have a pretty good idea what a
financial advisor makes
correct yeah and that feels really good
when we think about that future correct
yes all right there's a lot of potential
there of course there is you can make
crazy money
but it's not about the money it's about
the meaning isn't it
yes there we go it's about helping
people there it is so here's the deal
you're very very normal anna
it's normal everything you're feeling is
normal but you got to go hey this is not
about the now this is about the next
and if that's a wrestling match that
everybody deals with
i still deal with it i'll be 47 next
year it's not an age thing it's just a
human thing
but you've got some extenuating factors
that are kind of making you go oh i
don't know
and you're a little doubtful and i hope
i've brought you back to clarity
is this in your suite is this in your
sweet spot yes or no
yes yes it is are you on a ladder
that's going to get you to where you
want to go yes or no
yes eventually i know but you're on the
ladder
last time i checked there's multiple
rungs on a ladder and i gotta climb to
get to the top of it
you are climbing anna i'm proud of you
thank you so much for the call
i promise you you're doing the right
thing keep on doing it
the time will come for the next step
hey ken so
help me with this so talk about finding
your sweet spot
define that for me real quick well the
sweet spot is just a little analogy
that uh helps you see where you're using
what you do best your talent
to do work that you really love think
about the actual work itself
to then accomplish the results that you
want to put out into the world so when
talent passion and mission
align now you're in the sweet spot the
idea being with a baseball bat hits the
ball and that perfect part of the bat
we have maximum performance so she
mentioned
at the end of the day it's about helping
people that's right
and so i was about to ask you
is a sweet spot is it about skills i am
good at
talking with people so i could be a
salesman i could go get credentialed and
be a
um a counselor i could go fill in the
blank
or is it about mission i'm not helping
people so i could be a personal
financial planner i could go
learn the skills to work in i.t and help
folk
it's about all three it's all of it so
let's look at talent so let's just say
we'll use anna's example she's we've got
her on hold but let's say that anna's
talents are
communication that's that's the verbal
skills skills right it's just a verbal
talent
okay let's say that uh she's got the
talent of
logic right just a really good
analytical thinker you know and then
we'll throw one more in there
um maybe she's got the talent of uh
uh connection okay so that's not just
the ability to communicate but to really
connect with people
and so we go okay great that's what
you're really good at now what kind of
work do you love to do well she is she
has the talent of logic she probably
loves analyzing
um and she probably likes you know
taking that analyzing and and then she
if she likes communication then she
probably loves the work
of instruction right so and then you
look at okay she likes that she loves
that work
now we go what are the results that
matter to you she goes i'm really all
about
service and i'm really about
solution oh great so you put all that
together
you're really good at this blank and
blank that's talent okay you really love
to do this work
that's passion and you want to work to
produce these results service and
solution
so that means when you lay all that
together the sweet spot
let's just picture for a moment a big
circle inside of that circle are
multiple jobs and career paths
she just happens to kind of love the
finance side of things
but you have to hold it up so she's
listened to my show before i could tell
so i said are you in your sweet spot
she's going yeah because i want to use
my talents
for the mission that you're asking about
for service and solution but it's in the
area of finance
so let's back out of that and ask the
simon cowell
question what if i how do i know if i'm
talented in a thing
i work with a lot of people who think
they are real good at a thing
i'm not here at ramsey but i talk to
people i'm really good at x i'm good at
listening to my wife and she just
doesn't or i'm good
and i have to say yeah you're not well a
couple basic questions i love this
question a couple basic questions that
you've got to answer
uh what if people complimented you on
your whole life
now that's outside of uncle larry and
mama
you know what i mean and everybody at
thanksgiving we're talking real world
teachers
coaches right what have people
complimented you on here's another one
what has always come easy for you that
other people struggle at
okay we can begin to see these clues
right we kind of
uncover this and go oh people have
always said you're really good at
people of and then i watch other people
struggle in an area but
it's easy for me so what comes easy for
me what do people
compliment me on there's your basic
clues but here's the thing you got to
get real feedback
yeah okay you can think you're good at
it and you realize you're mediocre
yeah okay i thought i was a really good
soccer player until i started playing
really good soccer players and i
realized
i'm average yeah and so so
we can get clear on that by getting real
feedback and then putting ourselves
around other people that we know are
good and we measure ourselves
it's really hard to be delusional if you
do those things but if you're
but if you're only getting feedback from
your closest friends who aren't telling
you the truth
and your mom who would rather lie to you
than hurt your feelings
we end up with american idol moments
where somebody walks in and thinks they
can sing
and when simon tells them they suck they
literally
lose their mind and run out of the room
flipping people off and
beep beep beep and even the parents are
kind of like embarrassed
so i was i gave a talk here in nashville
at an event and it ended with a
standing ovation i thought i was pretty
good and one of dave's executives was in
the audience
and said i'm gonna hire that guy and
i went through the whole i you know went
through all the hiring process for a
year or whatever and all that
and then dave says man you got some
talent we're gonna make you into a good
speaker
and i said dave i think i'm a pretty
good speaker he looked at me and said
we'll get you there
okay he'll take some work and then you
look after
yeah a group of people who are world
class at what they do refining teaching
calling you out saying not good they're
not good enough there
then you look up a year a year and a
half later and you
you maximize those talents right that's
right
get real feedback from real people who
actually know what you're asking them
for feedback on
all right don't move more of your calls
coming up this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special
[Music]
savings
welcome back america if you're listening
to the ramsay show i'm kent coleman
joined by my colleague john deloney
we're taking your calls about your life
your money your relationships if you're
not where you want to be
it doesn't matter what area of your life
we'll take a shot at it triple eight
eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer custom
window coverage you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month
you'll save even more make sure you use
the promo code ramsey
to get the best deal today's question
comes from
sarah in utah i have two jobs as a
licensed
professional counselor one is at a
hospital where i work on an inpatient
unit full time
the other is a part-time private
practice i started last year
the hospital i work at was recently
bought by a new company things are
slowly improving
but before this it has been very
difficult
to work here with bad management i've
had one terrible raise in four years
there has been high turnover as well how
long do i hold out for a significant
raise with my new company
as well as for the work environment to
improve before i
leave well i you know the the asterisk
on this deal john
is when we get a question like this and
we can't go back and forth
it's very very tough so high level i
would give it a little bit of time with
the new company because it is after all
new
i would connect with the new leader if
in fact it is a new leader
the challenge with that is if it is the
same leader that she's had
and we just have new ownership then i
would say it's time to start looking
yeah
um in fact i would start looking anyway
but i would not leave
so i'd start looking now i would not
leave until i a found something better
or b if we've got new leadership truly
new leadership for you
and you've been able to address hey i've
been here this long this is what it was
like really excited you guys are here
what does the growth plan look like we
talk about growth plan not
let's talk about the laundry list of all
the things that are awful that's the
approach there john
whenever somebody asks the question how
long do i hold out for a significant
raise with my new company
as well as for the work environment to
improve
i want to look back at a few things one
is
you're working in a full-time inpatient
hospital
that works hard it's messy it's all the
time
it's heartbreaking there's only so much
that work environment can improve it's a
hard job
right when somebody says how do i how
long do i hold out for a significant
raise
i hear in my head that when i get x
amount of dollars that's going to make
all this worth it
and that hasn't been my experience
because you end up just making more
money in a
still really hard soul-sucking job right
so the other side of that though let me
mention this the other side of that john
is
how long do i hold out you shouldn't be
holding out
right for a significant race because i
got news for you if you're
holding out
it's not coming okay no it's if you're
not an organization where people
where the leadership develops you and
then promotes you
you're not in the right organization and
i've never seen a company be purchased
a new leader come in and say hey
everybody yeah so glad i'm here yeah
everybody 30 raised yeah that's right
new sheriff in town
drinks on me yeah that happens they'll
buy you drinks and donuts
i ain't giving you a 30 raise ah and
here's the thing
when you see your check with an extra
400 on it
you're not gonna suddenly go okay good
100
right this is a great point i get this
call daily on the ken coleman show
hey ken i took a job for a race six
months ago and i'm miserable yeah i know
yep because all you did was get an
initial high
because when we get promoted we feel
good about ourselves that's normal
and when we get more money we feel great
right so we
we feel some uh some love and we see the
love on the check
but that runs out pretty quick real
quick we humans adapt
so fast that if you're going into work
and you're not doing something that you
love
and you're not being treated as though
you matter and you don't have a ladder
to climb i'm telling you folks
it's it's not gonna last so whenever you
say the words
i'm just gonna hold out for that makes
you put you in what i would call an
imaginary position of power
that i'm i'm holding all the cars you're
not you're not
no right so what can somebody do here
ken if off top of my head you do this
all every day something on top of my
head
what's the amount of money you want to
make
what is the market going to pay for this
particular job in this particular area
are you good enough to meet that market
demand can you make this stuff
how much money do you think you need how
much money is this skill worth
is this the only shop in town right what
is going to make you whole here
don't play the i'm just going to hold up
what is going to make you whole yeah
yeah well in this particular question
this is feels like a burned out person
is what it sounds
already burned out yeah and now you got
new ownership coming in and again i'm
i'm chilling out long enough to see are
there going to be some structural
changes above me
and i'm going to get some experience to
see is this really a new day
most likely it's not if it's not a new
day i'm going okay this is what i do
this is not a question of what do i do
with my life i get that a lot this is i
know what i want to do i'm not making
what i want to make well let's look at
that to your point market research
what is it what is it pay do you have
the experience and the skill set to be
able to do that
but here's the thing before you make the
switch
do your homework it takes you
approximately
one day to figure out if a company's got
a pretty decent culture that's right
it's not a hard thing to discover and
dude
i deal with this with relationships with
a new girlfriend or a new husband or a
new wife or a new
whatev you do this with jobs never
forget man wherever you go
you go with you so if you don't have
a a life that is sustainable if you
don't have
connection with friends and community if
you don't have hobbies and things that
bring you joy if you don't have your own
mental health practice and your own
spiritual practice
go work another place make money lose
money what you're going to continue to
chase and chase and chase
because wherever you go you're going
with you so
sarah while you're waiting for this to
find out is this culture going to shift
and turn over
give these new owners time to get to
know the landscape
figure out the finances learn how utah
works whatever's going on in your
community
give them a while they're doing that
don't just sit there in the corner of
the arms crashed
with shooting lasers out of your
eyeballs at them you start working on
you
that's right right yeah well it's very
important to point out so
a couple years ago we did the largest
study of net worth millionaires that's
ever been done
10 000 plus net worth millionaires and
this never
ceases to amaze me folks you got to
understand this the third
largest group of net worth millionaires
in the united states of america are
teachers teachers okay
what all right this is even more fun the
median salary
in the united states for teachers the
median across the entire country 60
000. what's going on there so at some
point
it's not always about the raise and the
money it's more about hey
do i feel like i matter to this
organization and it doesn't even have to
be a massive race
your standard raise again in in the
united states is about three percent
okay that's a standard uh and
i i caution people to say hey it's not
about the raise
it's about do you feel like you're
growing while still doing what it is
that you want to do
and a lot of times you made a very good
point made me think of this you can be
growing too
absolutely you don't always have to
attach your growth
to a race do we want to raise yes but
why do i bring up teachers
they're in it for the work they're in it
for the mean it's why i teach
this you use what you do best to do work
you love
to produce results that matter to you
and at some point
you're going to have to say i have
enough money
because of the meaning and you and i
have talked about this extensively
in this great american dream that is now
morphed into
virtual you know i mean uh reality stars
and
private jets and bling we're starting to
really lose fact
of the facts around meaning yeah and
meaning has nothing to do with money
and i offer nothing we'll see somebody
who makes
137 000 and think
your life would be better if you made 92
because then you could go to all the
baseball games you wouldn't have to miss
the dance recital you could slow down a
little bit you could have
sunday off right instead of hustling on
top of hustling right
so that's answer that question what is
enough when are you whole when are you
well
and then plugging yourself in here
here's the thing sarah you got to heal
man
some people hurt you they took advantage
of it you had crappy leaders
don't take what they did to you and
throw that on your new leader
yeah heal from that too right i agree
and uh you wouldn't believe how many
seven figure earners are miserable
lots i just want to drop that in there
all right he is
dr john delany i'm ken coleman this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
deloney
hey we're talking about your life your
money your work your relationships and i
can tell you i know
that there's at least one thing that
sucks and it never stops sucking and
that's living paycheck to paycheck at
the end of the month
if you're barely covering all your bills
and never getting ahead
it's like getting stuck in a revolving
door with your money but you don't have
to live like this we want you to stop
this
and start making progress check out
ramsey plus this membership will show
you how to make the changes you need to
get the results you
want with your money ramsay plus
gives you complete access to our best
online money courses financial peace
university and know yourself know your
money
get out of the cycle start making real
progress
get a free trial of ramsey plus today
text trial
to 33789 that's trial text that to 33789
oh this is fun look at that name over
there john i i guess that name's
i guess that name's real marie claire
isn't that like a magazine or something
marie how can we help hi thank you so
much for taking my call it is a magazine
unfortunately it's not my magazine or i
probably wouldn't be in this
i thought so i thought so i wondered if
i'd seen that somewhere before okay how
can we help
yeah yeah yeah hey listen marie my call
my last name rhymes with the lunch meat
so you're doing okay
you're doing all of our crosses today
right yes
i'll trade you lunch meat for a magazine
any day good call
oh that's awesome um so i uh my husband
and i
are um just starting the program i mean
i've definitely
like thrown myself into it i'm listening
to the podcast i'm like i'm all in i'm
like so excited so i just did
my budget i do want to sign up for the
ramsey plus program and do the whole
story
now as you know the market the real
estate market is super crazy right now
so i just on a whim i called my real
estate agent because i just had to know
what my house is worth
and basically at the end of the day we
could
after paying her the six percent and
paying off all of our debt which is for
about forty nine thousand dollars of
consumer debt
and our cars uh we would be left with a
hundred and forty four thousand and
eight hundred dollars left
so i've heard a couple other people call
well so that's okay so we would we would
rent something for a short time we do
also have three kids and a dog so it's a
lot of stuff to do but
you know we my husband got a job in at
disney in disney
a couple years ago and we just decided
to move up there we didn't love it we
came back
so we we're open to moving around it's
not
you know it's not like we haven't done
it before um so we'd have to rent for
a couple years uh until the market
obviously
goes down a little bit or at least
levels out but in the meantime we could
bank
about 35 000 we budgeted about 35 000 to
budget a year
if we really stick to our budget and add
more to our wealth
we could have a pretty good sizeable
down payment for when we do
purchase another home i like it why
wouldn't you do that
well um you know i talk to everybody and
everybody that i know that
has any sense says it's a great business
decision to do it and then i talk to my
mom and she's like
don't get rid of your house if you love
and i say you know if i
i do love my house we've done a lot of
work to it but we also got at a really
good price
and now it's a really high price so i
just feel like as a business decision
we can always make another house a home
i just
our our worries are number one my
husband has a 1099 and it's a new job
and it's an international business so he
gets paid through paypal and then he has
a company that he pays himself
so it would take a couple years of a
1099 consistently
to be able to get another mortgage which
i already know that
um so that's a little bit of a scary
thing and also what the house prices are
going to be
in a couple years and we don't want to
rent for five years you want to rent for
two to three years max and it worries us
because no one knows
what's going to happen you know okay so
listen the flip side of that is is you
only got 49 left
that's that's my yeah and but yeah i get
it but i mean
i don't think this is a either or wrong
or right i think it's
up to what you guys decide i think it's
a i think you get fast forward on a lot
of things and i don't think renting is
that big of a deal
i've done it with three with three kids
and a dog uh
but at the same time i think you guys do
the pros and cons on this
and i think you could pay off the 49 if
you're going to put 35 away a year so
you kind of lay
that out well that means off in a year
and a half a year and a half you're done
yeah and you're in your house
and then uh we're feeling pretty
comfortable right
well that's 35 000 is us being able to
save without any debt
oh yeah with us saving with set
that's definitely not going to be it's
not going to be a two-year story no
unfortunately how much how much what's
your take-home income
what's your income it's 84 000. so he
his our income is 84 000 a year
that's before taxes i don't think we
haven't filed yet not exactly sure what
expenses and all that
it'll be do you stay at home i stay at
home i do i am a hairdresser but at the
at the cove and i stop doing the few
people that i do but i don't really
bring home
i bring home like the cash what kind of
debt is it
it's consumer debt and cars yeah i owe
about 8 400 on my car
and my husband owes about 6 000 on his
and they're both reliable vehicles but i
think we should keep them because
we need a car that fits everybody and
then he needs a car for work
um and um we don't use our credit cards
anymore i mean
we're done with the spending we're on a
pretty strict budget but we haven't
really we didn't we're not
as focused as we need to be here unless
you're in love with the house john i
that you and i may differ on this i
would probably sell the house
and do what you plan to do because it
fast forwards everything
and that's the thing if we want to stay
in our house we have to put an addition
on
we want a pool by the time we can afford
those things our kids are little but we
want to enjoy those things
sooner you know we don't want to be 55
putting an addition on a house you know
by the time we get into the right
financial place to do that
yeah never knowing the future but but
addition so yeah i this you're you're
luck you're getting the best of both
here because you're
ken's telling you he's a father of three
we have the same job
i would probably ken said i'll probably
sell the house here's what i my thought
is
i would put pools aside
and additions inside those are cool
wants it would be nice to have
i would say i'd rather see you
smile at the kids go guns-a-blazing
you go take every hairdressing
appointment you could possibly get your
hands on for the next 16 months
and tell your husband we're going into
defcon mode
like war games we're going to solve this
and pay that house off i mean pay your
debt off
everybody breathes and then you get to
look at the landscape what i would hate
for to see you
see happen you got no home three little
kids
your husband's international business
that pays him through paypal
dries up and you all are stuck in a in
an apartment somewhere
and you're thinking oh my gosh what to
do now right
so here's the thing that's those are two
different risk profiles on the same
question well
well i i don't know i i'm going to say
this i if the paypal thing or the
husband's business goes up it doesn't
matter whether you're renting or paying
mortgages
that's true so that that to me that fear
isn't relevant to this decision that
could happen whether i'm renting
yeah or not and at that point i'd rather
be renting
than i would be yeah i mean right it's
true exactly with all the expenses of
having a house and honestly i love my
house but
if i never said put in it again i would
be okay oh my gosh
if my wife said that to me i'd have the
house on the market tonight yeah why
didn't you lead with that marie claire
you know honestly it's me i'm the one
who wants to sell
more i mean my husband is on board and
we both have the same
we have the same uh hesitations because
we don't want to run forever but
you know you're not going to go that's a
that's a false
narrative you're going to fast forward
your life
tremendously and true
because you're i know you and you're
going to ask eight other people this
question
yeah that's right lead with lead with
if i never set foot in this house again
i would be fine lead with that
okay and they'll just say sell the house
i like it yeah you know what awesome
stop talking to people just go do it
talk to your husband
stop talking to mom it's not mom's
decision it's your decision it's your
hubs decision
stop talking to people to get their
opinion who gives a crap what they think
this is a fast forward button i'd press
it
and those cars are paid off i mean wow
we got options make it rent go rent a
house
make it fun make it an adventure keep
saving money 35
000 a year you guys are gonna be
crushing it
ah this is a no-brainer dude yeah
leave florida go somewhere where the
housing is cheap and you guys are gonna
love your life
or stay in florida i don't care yeah
i like it good for you i'm always
should open a magazine she should she
should write a column
i'm debt free and give it away to marie
claire maybe she develops a whole
college we're
we're brainstorming hey our producers
ben hill thank you ben
kelly daniel our call screener and
associate producer
and john delaney my colleague thank you
for joining us this is the ramsey show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of
ramsey advice in their life let them
know about the ramsey call of the day
podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show it's where
america hangs out
to have a conversation about life that
could be money
it could be relationships it could be
your work and career it could be mental
health emotional health hey we're
talking about it all because it all
matters you matter i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague
dr john dolone the phone number to jump
in is triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's start it
off
this hour in san antonio texas joshua is
on the line joshua how can we help
oh hey um just i heard you're talking
about talking about magazines the
next caller um just wanted to say i do
have my name
my name is magazine um it's called uh
uh l and a health magazine i just wanted
to
let you know all right very good thank
you for that
um my my my question is
do i follow my talent or passion
uh um that magazine
so um my my apparently my
professor thinks i'm good at writing
papers so that
that magazine was actually in an
internship
and so so i did the magazine she thinks
i'm
telling passionate mission so so i'm
talented i write the papers
i i can get behind the mission of of any
company
that that has me writing papers but i
have no talent
i have no passion for providing papers
oh
so you're really so you're really good
at writing but you don't enjoy writing
no what do you think what do you think
you do enjoy if you were going to take a
stab at something or
do you know what kind of work that you
would love to do
i do i i i that was next uh a
photojournalism
i loved i loved uh taking pictures like
um photojournalism was my favorite class
in college like i was taking notes i
couldn't even look at the professor
it was like my favorite class i was
taking notes
like so many notes in that class it was
like and then it was during covet but
i didn't care it was like the best class
ever okay so
so i shouldn't about flooded journalism
i can get behind the mission
but tell it so i mean there's so many
photographers
like and then and then um no one's
calling me
no one's calling me to go be on their
photography team and just and just to
discourage me more i applied to i
applied to be a photojournalist
for my school and they denied me so
so apparently i'm not a talented whole
journalist well wait a second wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait okay hold
on
all right so just because you got denied
doesn't mean you don't have talent
um let me connect the dots for a second
if you're if you're talented at writing
in some form or fashion i would call
that storytelling and
photojournalism is tor is telling
stories through a lens
and i'm privileged to know a couple of
uh photojournalists that
um are world-renowned uh and and
they are great storytellers and and i'm
not talking just with their work you
meet them and you get to know them
and you and you realize they're great
storytellers whether they have a camera
in their hands or not
the thing that i want to make sure of is
that that you
hone in on what are the talents
that are absolutely for
a photographer to have because because
i'm curious to know if you are a
creative person
would you say yes or no that you are
creative and everybody's creative
but are you creative uh as it relates to
visual things
yes i mean like creative as a like i
don't know what i mean
i take my camera everywhere i go i mean
um uh
i'm the photographer of the family i
mean i'm always taking pictures of the
sunrise fence that looks creative
i mean i mean um what would you rate
yourself what would you rate yourself on
one to ten
as a photographer be honest as honest as
you can
i mean i mean i compare myself too much
so yeah i wouldn't say rate myself i'm
preparing myself
no no no i didn't ask you i didn't ask
you to compare yourself i asked you to
rate your photography when you take it
you've studied enough photography to
know and i'm okay if you're a little bit
down on yourself
what would you rate yourself yourself
your photos
okay then the six okay now here's what i
know
joshua a six
can bust his butt that's
youtube videos watching some of the best
photographers that's lighting lenses i
mean you just go to school on what the
great photographers are doing
and then you start to adopt some of
those practices and you see if you can
see a difference in your photography
then you got to show your work
and don't get discouraged because you
applied for a position at school you got
turned down
what you got to do is take a lot of
photos so if you got to go get a day job
right now to take care of you
go get yourself a day job being a
photojournalist
is a job that you will probably earn
your way into by showing your work and
you can do this on the side so it takes
the pressure off of you
so listen to me a six can turn into an
eight
maybe with a lot of hard work over a
long time
maybe a nine and people will pay for
nine people will pay for eight so
i want you to commit to
really training yourself and if you got
to take some online courses or some
other classes
that are local even a community college
photography class
go take it become a human sponge who are
your favorite photojournalists i want
you to answer that question by the end
of this week
who are your three favorite
photojournalists even if you don't have
them go find them
and you begin to soak and study
everything they do
and then you commit to being that and
you show your work and over time
i believe you can do that but this is
not gonna be something that happens
overnight if you're willing to do that
then i think you can can succeed here
but there's one last piece
as you're doing all that i want you to
eventually get to know some
photojournalists
uh in your area in san antonio texas and
show them your work
people that you that you don't know and
say hey i want you to be brutally honest
with me
do i have the artistic talent with these
photos
if i work on it and i take tips from you
and other people
can i be really really good that's the
last piece there you do that young man
then it's all about starting out and
sticking with it
so ken man probably the most common
question i get asked is something
passion related
i'm not passionate about my husband
anymore i'm not passionate about this
job anymore
i like the this part of the job and i'm
not passionate about this
i just quit my experience
with passion and i'd love to hear
because this is what you do for a living
you help people like me who are grumpy
on passion
i feel like passion has become a god
that we worship and passion we've turned
into does it feel good all the time
and i the things i am passionate about
in my life
are things that i have become good at
and i've only become good at things that
i have
practiced over and over and over and if
i'm honest with myself
a lot of that initial practice came
because i was forced to
whether when i was a young kid it was
like if you're gonna be on a team you're
gonna show up if you show up you're
gonna practice your work hard
or if it was deloney we're gonna send
you that draft back we're gonna send
that draft back and i've got to keep
working on my writing and working on my
writing work in my writing
and then over time i grew to love
writing that can happen
and i agree with you that passion has
been distorted okay
i define passion as this work you
love it's for the love of the work i
love
showing up and writing stuff from
scratch or i love
taking photography if you only pursue
something that you have a talent for but
you just don't get juiced
i think it's 50 50 at best that you
develop a love for it so i agree
with you that it's become distorted it's
not about feeling can we get back on
this this is about
this will be good okay great all right
we'll unpack it yeah
there's a method to the madness this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
so
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month get
unlimited talk text and
six gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
dr john delony the phone number to jump
in on the conversation about
you and your life and progress where you
are looking for it
breakthrough triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to chicago illinois
where chad joins us chad how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call i
appreciate it you bet what's up
well uh tonight i'm going on a birthday
dinner with my bride and
i need to bring up um finances
again and uh you know i read the total
money makeover a few years ago and i
i understand the baby steps and
you know step one's done working on step
two but it seems
a bit one-sided and she's not fully on
board
which makes things difficult so is it
your birthday or her birthday
my birthday happy birthday hey chad
thank you yeah
i'm just gonna take a stab in the dark
here okay
okay um
a guy who wants to talk finances
at his birthday dinner may be a guy
that doesn't always have the right
timing to talk about hard conversations
and maybe has a wife who is really
gifted
at tuning out and nodding because
chad's got a lot of ideas about a lot of
things in a lot of different places
am i onto something or no tell me if i'm
wrong i said the first part's right
okay i would like to second
my colleagues under no circumstances is
tonight the night
gosh to talk about how she needs to get
on board with the finance issues
this is your birthday brother enjoy your
birthday yeah you're gonna kill
the night and i don't know what big
ideas you had in mind
so back us out of here so you got all
excited
tell us what she said when you when you
like hey
babe you got to watch the youtube shows
you got to read the books you gotta i'm
all in
let's be all in what was her response
well she's she gets behind the idea
but then um you know didn't
doesn't really have the time to i'd say
put into that
then she's not behind the idea what is
it about the presentation
of the idea the information what is it
about it all
that she won't investigate it because if
you came and said hey
i've picked us two two vacation spots
that i paid for in full either hawaii
or london i need you to sit down and
look through these with me
she'd sit down and look through so what
about this
this life-changing journey y'all could
go on
that she says yeah it sounds great i
just don't have time right now
you know i i think it has a lot to do
with the past and
kind of the upbringing with money and
you know we don't
we don't have we have separate things
financially now you know five
six years in the marriage one i think
just making that
why do you have that
you have kids well yes we have kids now
so she runs her own business so she runs
a lot of things through
that's fine as well but you guys trust
each other enough to create humans why
don't you trust each other enough to
share a checking account
yeah like it seems like a sticking point
on
her side not my side and it may be of
however
you know parents did things and that's
just what she's familiar with okay
this is a marriage issue not a money
issue marriage first money second on
this deal
one thousand percent okay
my guess is there's other places where
y'all are on the same page am i right
no no chad
is the guy that's trying to talk finance
on his birthday dinner are there other
places where y'all are not
connected
i'd say no like we're
so here's what i want you to do tonight
i don't even think you know the answer
to that
exactly right i want you to ask her that
i'd say
no but yeah but there is something that
i don't know
let me tell you why i don't think you
know now john's the expert in this area
john i don't think chad knows because
she's got her own money
they got it's not their money it's her
money she's running her own business you
got her own bank account you don't know
where you guys are disconnected because
you don't have any say you don't have
any insight into
half if not eighty percent ninety
percent of what she's spending money on
so
i i think john is has uncovered
something here
right here's what you are talking about
here's what you are
you're really good human being
and you have a sweetheart and i think
you're a good husband and i bet you're a
great dad
are you a good dad yes yes
i 100 agree with that and
i think you are a great roommate
and it feels like your wife and you are
living parallel lives
and can nailed it on the head
with a mallet this is not a money issue
this is not a how can you convince her
to get on the same page and do the dave
ramsey plan
this is a we're running on parallel
tracks here
we share kids and we share a home and so
i would love to see tonight's dinner be
about for my birthday hun
i want us to go rappel deep off the edge
here
into how long you've been married five
years you said
i'm gonna be six gonna be six
honey let's paint a picture what would
you if you could snap your fingers what
would the next six years
look like what would it look like not
just talk about it
i'd like to know what would it look like
where would we be sitting where would we
be
living what would our kids be doing what
would that vision look like
how would we get there together how
would i need to do how could i support
you how could i
live into this how could you support it
i want you all to create a vision
together that'd be a great birthday
present not when we talk about finances
finances comes when you start reverse
engineering that dream
and say well here's how we have to live
today so that that thing can happen
tomorrow
but you're not there yet absolutely
right
chad i mean that's the plan man and do
not
start talking about money if she starts
sharing dreams stay in dreamland
stay in dreamland don't take it to the
money it's your birthday for heaven's
sakes
gee you're gonna party like it's your
birthday
yeah right yeah wow how does that go
drink bacardi like
yeah it's your birthday chad so listen
can i for anybody listening if you
on any issue are just
not connecting with your spouse trying
to
give more information or say it louder
say it quiet or say it in spanish say it
in
that's not the issue the issue is
there is some sort of defense mechanism
whether as chad said maybe it's it's
from their childhood
maybe it's they're tired because you're
always got a scheme maybe it is this is
dave ramsey's plan is one of 50 weight
loss plans you get rich plans
and this is just another one in a series
whatever the thing is
it's a connection issue and you've got
to get beneath that and say honey when i
bring this up
what about this scares you what about
this when i say hey i would love to get
out of debt and change our family tree
what is it about me communicating this
i'm not doing a good job of selling it
because the freedom part
feels right what about this scares you
and let them say
i don't want to give up vacations i
don't want to get a second job i like
staying at home with the kids i don't
want to feel
let's have that conversation otherwise
you're just
two people two trains going on the track
and you bump into each other every once
in a while
and you just keep going and going and
going yeah i
here's what i've learned from 23 years
of marriage and i've learned it from me
blowing it
so i want to be very clear right here
this is not an expert opinion this is
the day
this
we make mistakes when we try to talk
about strategy instead of direction
we must as john was saying you got to
get connected so there's a connection
on direction once the connection is made
on direction then we can start to figure
out but we've got to be on the same page
about what mountain we're trying to
climb
it's worthless to talk about strategy
you can talk all you want to hey here's
how we climb around here's how we climb
around here's climbing
and if we're both thinking about
different mountains it's a problem
people make the mistake and he wants to
talk strategy yeah
she's not even on board with direction
it's worthless to say hey we need to do
this
this this and this and go whoa why would
we do this we've all seen a football
team
whether it's a professional one or you
play it on like in high school or
college
the coach comes in and says here's my
one goal i want to win games
but there's always a receiver who wants
to get a lot of yards
yeah and so when the coach says hey we
need to run these plays this week
oh come on i'm not going to get any
catches i'm not going to need touches
right
you got two competing directions there
right you got to get everybody together
yeah good stuff all right well
we've been there we've done it speaking
of been there done it
we're not done yet we have more to go
folks more of your calls
coming up he is dr john dolone i am ken
coleman and this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman i'm joined by my colleague dr
john dolone
and we are coming to you from our
ramsey solutions world headquarters
gorgeous
gorgeous place by the way we've had a
great crowd that have joined us today
and uh want to invite you to come hang
ramseysolutions.com
probably come view the show uh we've got
the uh beautiful cafe out there john
cookies uh hot beverages warm beverages
all of it it's fantastic and we love
meeting people so we'd love to have you
sometime
uh have you been paying attention john
to the real estate market because i know
you recently bought
and so you're like the new homeowner
you're kind of out there on the farm
about nine months ago
have you paid attention to what it's
done it's
it's you know what my 11 year old has
gotten into monopoly
oh and there's a moment when you just
get in these little loops and your kid
owns 18 hotels and you just keep having
to
right it's like that it's like that yeah
it's monopoly money
it's hot so uh you know that competition
is
unbelievably intense inventory still
at all time lows and when that happens
it means there's more buyers buyer
excuse me more buyers buying than
sellers selling try to say that three
times very quickly
and so that's turning the heat up on
everybody uh
buyers want to get the right house
sellers want to get the right offer so
this isn't a time for amateurs and this
is probably going to be this way for a
while so to win in this market you need
a pro
by your side helping you buy or sell our
endorsed local providers who are real
estate pros
have years of industry success and
they're going to help you win
whatever your goal is here in this
market so you can connect with an
endorsed local provider in your area
today go to ramseysolutions.com
agent that's ramseysolutions.com
agent to find a ramsey trusted agent
near
you triple eight eight two five five two
two five
is the phone number let's go to taylor
in chicago illinois taylor how can we
help
hey guys i feel so privileged to talk to
you both oh well we are the one that are
privileged
so what's going on so about
a year and a half ago my husband
was let go
basically in a nutshell he really
struggled to communicate
boundaries at work and it wasn't like
they were
asking him to work more than 40 hours
but the kind of work that they were
putting on his
plate was so high intense
that when he did ask for more help um it
was refused
and they told him to do a time study and
it was kind of a mess
and i should press this up by saying
he's like crazy gifted
and efficient and so they even
they told him he was gonna get a raise
and then they never delivered but they
still added more on his plate
without fed rays um and so
it really started affecting our home
life um
you know our marriage and our children
and just
so many things and then when things got
to a really bad breaking point um
you know it just it just couldn't be in
the ministry anymore
so we're in a much better spot now
praise god i mean
like i said he's been home for a year
and a half he thank god he has a
youtube channel that does really well um
but we're
really committed to getting out of this
little debt that we have left um so he's
got a warehouse job on the weekends but
the s goal is to maybe get back in
ministry but we're so
terrified so terrified because he's
terrified and i'm prepared because what
if it happens again like what if we fail
to set those boundaries or
he fails to set those boundaries and
he's a yes guy like
you know if if you want him to jump
he'll say how high where
how long he's just he's an amazing
worker and you're an amazing purpose
person yeah but it ended up filling into
other parts of our family and life and
it's just
yeah it's hard yeah uh john
is going to jump in here it can really
help uh but i'm curious
what position was he in and it was it a
para church ministry was it a church
it was a church he was a pastor staff
pastor um
a worship pastor and he i mean like i
said they gave well they promised to
raise and
and then after finally asking three
times hey where's the razors raised we
finally gave it but it wasn't nearly
what it was promised yeah okay so um
i want john to speak to the boundaries
issue but i want to make a statement
that i hope you take back to your
husband
um maybe maybe he can watch this on
youtube because we're talking about him
yeah um yeah he'd call but like i said
he's working pretty much 80 hours a week
now
yeah well so here's the deal the fear
that every church leadership structure
is going to be like it was is just
nonsense
it's just nonsense he knows what an
unhealthy leadership structure looks
like
he can identify it he can taste it smell
it point it out a mile away
and he needs to be armed with that
confidence that that's not always going
to be the case
but he's a part of the equation too
that's where i hand the baton to my
much more capable colleague on his
boundary issues well
you know i mean i could guess what it is
but not talking to him
but uh he he can't assume so that fear
is misguided right that needs to be
just blown up but his boundary issue is
part of the problem
here's a big part the fear is the fear
is real
it's real yeah so what's happened is you
guys got fried
right and now both your hearts and your
brains are scanning every possible
environment that looks similar to say
hey we
know this story and it hurt us so i'm
gonna
keep us out of that right and to ken's
point
that's that's not a fair representation
on the other side
if as you say he can't say no he won't
do boundaries he will say yes to
everything i'm going to tell you
don't go into ministry because he's
going to make relationships with people
who love him and then they're going to
be hurt when that thing goes south
and if he can't say no if he can't
establish a
what is my work daily job what is my
salary what are the raised structures
what is my responsibilities when i'm off
if he can't do that
then he doesn't have the other side of
the skill set
of taking care of people which is taking
care of yourself
right right which i should say that he
has come
i i was listening you know we listen to
you guys every day our kids pretty much
asking us when we're going to be on the
dave ramsey so
doing our debt free screams um but
he's come so so far sure it's not like
we're roommates anymore
it used to be like that i used to tell
him two years ago i just feel like we're
just
living together and just kind of going
in circles
um so he's i mean when i tell you that
he's put in the work
i've we've read the proximity principle
this past month
i mean we're going through books and
we're he's and i want to be his
cheerleader and so he's
he's working on setting those boundaries
if that makes sense but it's
still like it's still a struggle here's
here's a great way you can bring it in
the smallest
places here's a great way you can do it
when there are boundaries to be set in
your home
and i'm talking about little stuff like
somebody knocks on the door
and normally you would go answer it and
say um no thank you we're not interested
he gets to go do that and when he comes
back i want him to verbalize to you
to be vulnerable and say that made me
uncomfortable
not listening to the whole pitch and go
ahead and buying the magazines even
though i didn't want them
if his mom or your mom or somebody's
family or somebody's friends invite you
all out and y'all don't want to go
he is the guy that's not gonna text he's
gonna call him and say
hey thanks for the invite we're not
gonna be able to make it this time no
excuses
no but next time just say
um we're not gonna be able to make it
this time but we look forward to
catching up next time then hang up and
then i want him to turn and look at you
and verbalize what am i feeling here
and all we're trying to do is two things
number one he's gotta practice
boundaries
and if he waits till the game to take a
shot
then he's gonna miss the shot right so
he's gonna practice you're gonna help
him practice
and two i want him to verbalize these
feelings that he feels that insecurity
that nervousness his heart starts racing
they're not going to kill him in fact
they're normal right
and so you're going to practice and
practice and practice and then yeah when
he goes in to apply for a job at his
next church
he's going to know hey i got burned on
this stuff last time i learned a great
lesson
now i know the questions to ask and if
the community is not right the community
is not right
but practice boundaries just like you
would any other skill
right yeah i just want to reiterate what
john said that i agree i think he does
need to get help and even counseling
that's great counseling right there but
i want him to get to the bottom of why
he feels he's got to say yes
because if he feels called i think he's
got to do it
but john's right don't get back into
ministry until he's healthy
and he can do it right uh that's good
but thank you for the call you guys are
amazing
you're killing it by the way he's a
great guy and dad i love it he's busting
right now what a stud and remind him
that you appreciate how hard he's
working that might be a little fun thing
you need to hear as well
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
welcome back america you're listening to
the ramsay show i'm ken coleman joined
by my colleague dr john deloney
and we're thrilled to have you with us
triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the phone number
triple eight eight two five
five two two five today's scripture
comes from joshua
1 9 which says have i not commanded you
be strong and courageous do not be
afraid do not
be discouraged for the lord your god
will be with you wherever you go
our quote today is from the legendary
lady rosa parks
you must never be fearful about what you
are doing
when it is right
awesome stuff there triple eight eight
two five
five two two five is the number let's go
to san diego california
where evelyn joins us on the line evelyn
how can we help
hey hi thank you for taking my call it's
such a privilege to speak to you
you bet what's going on i hey
ken i've gone back to school to get my
certificate
in marketing okay and the company that i
work for now they had an internal
position in the marketing department and
i
applied for it and during my interview
the hiring manager thought i would be
a good fit for another position
but when i read the job description it
doesn't really
appeal to me and it's not really
anything relevant to what i have learned
for my marketing certificate so i'm just
wondering
do i you know put my head in the ring
again
no uh just uh getting my foot in the
door
or hoping that maybe another position
would come up
or i thought you would like it okay so
when you say foot in the door
i thought you were already in the
company i am in the company i'm in
another
department i mean so you've been so okay
so so uh maybe i say yeah i said no
pretty quickly but let me just double
check myself
so okay uh you you applied for one
position or your instrument and then
they said well i think i recommend you
over here
and you look at it and you go i'm not
interested in that at all
um so that's why i said no now
then you said foot in the door so if you
mean to move over to a different
department
that is where you ultimately want to be
um if you can pull the gig off and
you're not going to be miserable six
months after you take it
and you got some patience and it gets
you in that department
i say take it that's the proximity
principle i wrote an entire book on that
you get in the places where the work
that you want to be doing
is happening and in this situation if if
you're in the marketing department in a
role that is not
ultimately where you want to be but it
gets you in over there now you're
connecting
you've got relationships we're doing
lunch with these people we're seeing
them every day
you've got this community college class
you're getting that marketing skill that
certification that you want
i think it's a great move but i'm
telling you the caveat is
you can't get miserable and you can't
get all you know
impatient six months in knowing that i
took this position to get in
and now i'm looking for the next
position and if you can do that and i
think you can
this is a maturity issue then i would
say yes
but if it was just to take a position uh
because it was a little bit better than
the one you're in and it didn't have a
long
term uh tie to it then i would say no
does that make sense
yes that's that does so should i give
myself let's
let's say you know i go for it
everything happens
and i get the position should i give
myself
six months and let's say i'm like
miserable
apply for a position at an outside
company or
just um you know
what do i do just mature up and what
about that what about this job you seem
to be
convinced you're gonna end up miserable
what about this job
you're hedging your best that this all
just goes to crap
yeah look at that i'm just saying that
because when i
look at the position
it isn't anything that like i said that
i
learned in the certification program
that i was in
it you said it well you said it well it
doesn't interest you
and i'm fine with that i mean but not
every job is
remember not every job is the dream job
it's stage six
okay for me in my seven stages but
but i do i think you have to listen to
that but let's go back to what you just
said
should i look for something outside how
much longer before
you get done with the certification
process and then you're qualified
in your mind to to uh to go after the
marketing position you're looking for
well i have years of experience um
and in the industry that i'm trying to
um become like a product manager for
okay but i have that experience but i
just don't have the marketing
certificate which i believe the
marketing
right so how much longer before you get
the certificate
oh i'm done in september i only have one
more class fantastic
so i would be looking internally and
externally yeah is this the greatest
company on earth to work for
no no no i mean there's like
plenty of fish in the sea right now but
i mean are you this is just where i am
now
right so you're not you're you don't
have this deep value connection
missional connection you know i teach
talent passion and mission you don't
have this big missional connection to
this company correct
correct oh i would start looking today
and start looking externally
yeah absolutely okay and i would and
again i'm gonna go back to my initial
answer i think the answer is no
i didn't know that you had all this
qualification i didn't know that you had
all this experience
i would not take this position that this
manager suggested to you you don't have
any interest in it
i don't think it i i just don't think
that it sets you up
long term because you're already
qualified and you've already got good
experience
start looking for the thing you want to
do or the closest
rung on the ladder to the thing you want
to do and go do
that that's what you need to do because
you're stable right now
right okay then i have one more question
all right um
so i got the email yesterday he sent me
the
description how do i write back to him
and say you know
thank you for your interest but no thank
you in a
in a you know
correct way without you know step you
know hurting any feelings
evelyn you just gave yourself you
answered your own question uh
i like to call it i like to call it a
thank you sandwich thank you for
thinking of me thank you for
recommending this to me
i've slept on it i've considered it and
i don't think it's the right
move for me right now but i'm humbled
and honored and again
grateful that you thought of me i think
i need to pass on this however you want
to save
that right there that's your thank you
humble
thank you and if you could do it in
person all the better yeah
that's that's been it's that went to bat
for you to try to find you a job on his
marketing team
yeah to get you in the door and he's
going to feel a little bit burned on it
man just go go see him
i love that i look at this job
description man i like that too
because i'm more of an in-person person
yeah okay pop by the office
and now here's the deal evelyn you
strike me as a really really really nice
lady you need to expect and john i want
you to address this you need to expect
that he's going to go are you sure and
he pitches which is okay that's
his job hold the line right go back to
i'm really grateful thank you trust me i
thought about it from every angle
thank you but i really got a pass or
i went and i got rid of the rest of the
candidates for you
you told me you wanted to do this i made
this happen for you i got you in the
door here
yes okay i'll try it all right you're
right so you got to hold the line
hold the line hey when she when evan was
first talking ken
here's my here's how i the analogy that
popped in my head tell me if i'm off
here because you you answered no right
as i was thinking it
if somebody came to me and said hey
listen i know you
aren't happy in your current dating
relationship
i got a guy who's
nothing y'all share no interest at all
not attractive at all
but somebody else may see you dating
this guy
and they may be interested later you
should go out with them
right my first i was thinking no if
somebody presented that to me right no
i'm not gonna do that yeah
yeah again you gotta trust your heart
yeah
it's the heart check oh wait a second am
i interested in this work
because here's what i know folks when
and this is for people who have a clear
direction on where she wants to go
she does and so when someone has a clear
direction and somebody offers you
another direction i'm fine with checking
it out but it must lead back to the
destination
so i'm a fan of multiple directions i
don't preach that there's only one job
or one career for people i don't preach
that yeah what i do preach is
there's a unique role you're supposed to
fill but in this situation yeah it was
instantaneous that no i think you're
absolutely right
you can't force something because the
heart will not lie
and it'll pop its head back up you your
head will talk to you
and tell you to do it essentially the
heart goes i'm still here you idiot
and then you get into the disengagement
at work and that's a whole other show
that's right hey thanks pal
my friend my colleague great stuff there
i want to thank our producer ben hill i
want to thank our associate producer and
call screener kelly daniel
and you america this is the ramsay show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you